hi my name is amelia clark i'm on game  of thrones and this season i get to kick  some serious butt  i  do like a guy being chivalrous i'm  slightly old-fashioned at heart when it  comes that kind of thing someone opening  a door for me is hugely appreciated  daenerys however would be less  appreciative of a man being shovel wrist  because she's pretty much chivalrous for  herself  so my idea of an ideal first date would  probably be old-school old-fashioned  dancing daenerys's idea of an ideal  first date i think would probably be  somewhere in the desert with a horde of  dothraki  between my beloved father and my dragons  the person that you should probably be  more alarmed at meeting  would probably be  yeah my dad